- I use my phone incessantly.
- My phone is basically my boredom box.
So anytime I get really bored
that's the first thing I go to.
- I'm so attached to my phone
it's almost embarrassing.
- It's like I never put it down, ever.
- Oh.
- God.
- If I had to guess I would say
maybe around 45 minutes a day.
- Humidive-ly, if you
condense it all together,
an hour-and-a-half?
- I think I'm on my phone like
an hour.
- Maybe like 13 hours, like a day.
- I feel like I don't
check my phone that much.
I've always kind of tried to pride myself
on being one of those people.
So I would guess I check
my phone 30 times a day.
- There's a, like big period of time
where I don't look at it.
I just ...
What, why?
- I have a feeling I might
not like what I find out,
but I know I probably am not gonna change.
- I am so scared that I am the problem.
I am the person that I hate.
- You know what's weird?
My phone is such a big part of my life
and I have no idea how much I use it.
- So now I'm home and this is definitely
when I check my phone a lot more.
- It's actually kind of embarrassing
how much I've been using my phone.
- Okay, so confession time.
I'm at a dinner with friends
and the first thing I
did was go on my phone
and check my email.
- So I'm home from work now
and I'm gonna guess my phone usage
is gonna double or triple.
- So I'm checking my
Instagram in the shower.
- I'm trying to get off my phone
so I can go to bed.
- I feel like I check it more compulsively
than I imagine, but maybe
for not quite as long.
I don't know.
We'll see what happens tomorrow.
- I'm really nervous to find out
how much I actually use my phone.
- Like I didn't realize how many things
I use my phone for that I didn't
really put in my estimate.
- I'm terrified of what
this will say about me.
- All right, here we go.
Ah.
- Oh my God.
That's like longer than
most movies I watch.
Oh, no.
- Whoa, 151 times.
Holy shit.
Well, I got business to attend to.
I gotta reply to everybody.
- Whoa.
That is not any where near
as bad as I thought it would be.
Three hours I'm like totally fine with.
- Yeah, this seems right.
This seems right.
This isn't mind blowing knowing myself.
- Oh my God, no.
No.
Oh, I was completely
wrong on like all counts.
Oh my God.
- Woo.
Okay, 138 pickups to me
that's a lot of checking my phone.
That's a lot of just
constantly going, huh?
Huh?
- I was very wrong.
I'm really disgusted with myself.
This is horrible.
- Is this gonna change your phone habits?
- I don't think so.
I don't think so.
- I think it's gonna change what apps
I spend time with on my phone.
- I make fun of my friends so much
for being on their phone
while I'm talking to them.
Now I know clearly I am
also one of those people.
- For all of my friends who make fun of me
for being on my phone all the time
I'm actually fairly average.
- So my phone's gonna be a
big part of my life still,
but I'm gonna try and use
it in a more healthy way.
- It makes me think that maybe
I spend way too much
time stuck down like this
and it wouldn't kill
me to keep my head here
more often during the day in my life.